au niveau national le dialogue n'est pas
totalement rompu denis perben le
ministre de la fonction publique a reçu
cet après midi les syndicats de
fonctionnaires un dialogue avorté qui
s'est soldée sur un constat de désaccord
complet
reportage agnès molinier trouvera ici
c'est une première pour dominique perben
depuis qu'il est ministre de la fonction
publique qu'il n'avait jamais rencontré
ensemble les sept fédérations de
fonctionnaires mais l'heure n'est pas
aux sibilité rapidement la cgt quittent
la réunion
si on nous dit retire le plan juppé
si on nous dit on lève l'hypothèque
d'une hypothèque du blocage des salaires
si on nous dit on lève une série diplo
d'hypothèques relative au développement
du service public nous retournerons
négocier avec la ministre
mais le ministre avait seulement pour
mission cet après-midi d'expliquer aux
fonctionnaires que même si le plan juppé
prévoit un allongement de la durée des
cotisations
il n'est pas question de supprimer les
régimes spéciaux de retraite
il n'a jamais été question de
suppression des régimes spéciaux tout
l'objectif du gouvernement est au
contraire de consolider ces régimes pour
assurer leur avenir
s'il est vrai que nous avons mal compris
le premier ministre
il ya un moyen bien simple c'est
d'annoncer ce soir qu'il retire son
projet concernant les régimes spéciaux
mais rien n'est retiré ce soir les
syndicats appellent à élargir le
mouvement la commission le vert chargé
d'étudier l'avenir des régimes spéciaux
de retraite s'est réuni ce matin pour la
première fois quatre syndicats de
cheminots ont déjà décidé de la
boycotter ce sujet